[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOEL CONKLING: My
name is Joel Conkling.
I'm a product manager
for Earth Engine.
Earth Engine's the
petabyte-scale processing
platform for geospatial
data at Google,
used by a wide
range of industries
we've been developing
over the last 10 years.
And I'm excited to tell
you a little bit about it
and show you a few demos
that will illustrate
some of what it can do.
So when we think
about Earth Engine,
we think about two things--
one is it's a
massive data catalog
with open data from satellite
imagery, and many others,
and their computation
platform where you can analyze
that data in a variety
of different ways
to meet your use cases.
We see users from agriculture
industry, forestry industry,
oil and gas, natural resources,
and a wide variety of others.
And we'll go through a
use case here in a second.
And we'll do that through the
lens of an agricultural use
case.
So imagine you're
working at a company.
You have a customer who
is a farmer in Arizona.
He wants to know how his
agricultural fields are doing.
Maybe he's farming
corn, wheat, soy--
something like that.
And we're going to go
through a use case that shows
how that works in Earth Engine.
I mentioned the Earth
Engine data catalog.
It's about 500 data sets of
geospatial data, 30 petabytes
and growing with a wide
range of data types,
from climate and weather
data, imagery, and radar data,
geophysical, socioeconomic, air
quality data, and many more.
You can bring your own data
to our attention, as well.
So if you're doing
analysis where
you like open data and your
own data, that's easy to do.
And what that does is it
lets you get started faster.
So instead of figuring
out what data you need,
where do you find it,
how do you download it,
how do you pre-process it--
what you can do
with Earth Engine
is just identify that
data in the catalog
and start your work--
start your hypothesis.
And so I'm going to go to
a demo right now, which
will show us a little
bit about how that works.
So here with five
lines of code there
in the middle of
the screen, we've
pulled some data
in for analysis.
The first line
identifies the data set.
The second line says, what
date do we want to look at?
Here, on the third line,
we're doing some visualization
parameters, adding
it to the map,
and telling it what
part of the map to show.
I hit Run.
And you can see this data set.
This is Landsat 8.
It's a satellite imagery program
run by the US government.
It covers the globe
every 16 days.
We've asked it for one day.
And you can see the
path of the satellite
over the course of that day.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JOEL CONKLING: So we haven't
asked much of Earth Engine yet
in terms of computation.
But when you do start
to do computation,
you often start in
the Code Editor--
what we call the Code Editor.
And here at the
top in the middle
is where you write your script.
Right above that, there's a Run
button, which I used just now,
which gives you the
ability to run calculations
in Earth Engine.
And then you can look at your
results on top of the map,
either here at the bottom.
Or if you click
somewhere on the map,
you can see the results
in the top right.
You also have access to all of
your scripts, all of your data,
and documentation about
how to use Earth Engine
in the top left panel there.
In addition to the Code
Editor environment,
we also have programming APIs.
You can use those
programming APIs
in Jupiter colab notebooks--
environments like that-- or pull
data into your GCP work flows
with APIs, as well.
I want to go through a
series of additional demos
here where we'll start to answer
that question for the farmer,
how are my fields
doing this year?
The first thing
I'll do is show you
what it looks like when you
pull in 16 days of data, which
should give us pretty full
coverage of the United
States and the whole globe.
So that's given the
Landsat satellite
times to cover the entire globe.
As someone who's working to
answer questions for a farmer,
you might care about a
longer time series than that.
So I'll make this a
six-month time series.
And you can hit Run there.
And so, again, with
relatively few lines of code,
not that much work to do.
You're pulling in data from
six months worth of Landsat.
Hundreds of gigabytes of
data is at your fingertips.
And the Landsat catalog itself
goes back 30 or 40 years.
So you can go way farther
back in history of the map.
So we've also got this
median value here,
which is basically looking
at, over six months,
you've got 12 images for
each part of the planet.
It's looking at the
median value for each
of the bands in that image.
It turns out that clouds
are highly reflective.
So, if you want to find
clouds, change median to max.
And once that comes
up, you'll see
that there are clouds almost
everywhere over the United
States at some point during
that six-month period.
A quick and easy way
to mask out clouds,
which is a more
common thing to do
is you change that median
to a min and run that.
And you've got a decent
cloud-free mosaic of the United
States or anywhere in the globe.
Again, pretty simple and
easy to do an Earth Engine,
not that much work.
In the agriculture
space, you care how well
is your vegetation doing?
How healthy is your vegetation?
And one common way of doing that
is with a normalized difference
vegetation index or NDVI.
It's a pretty
simple calculation.
We start with the same
code that we had before
to bring that imagery in.
Define a function at NDVI, use
existing Earth Engine operators
to do that calculation.
It's one band minus
another divided by one
band plus another--
add the results to the image
that you're working on.
And then here, you map
that across all the imagery
in your collection.
Define the palette,
add it to the map.
Pick what part of the
map you want to show.
And in this case, I'm going
to show part of Arizona
where there's some agricultural
fields and hit Run.
And that'll start
pulling in NDVI data
on top of some imagery data.
So what that NDVI is showing,
as you get higher values that
goes to darker green.
And those dark green
values register
for where areas for
those lots of vegetation.
You can also move the
transparency sliders
up and down to get a sense of
what's behind that imagery.
You can toggle the
layers on and off.
So a variety of things you can
do to sort of inspect the data.
With a few more lines of
code, we can do a lot more.
And here, we're, again, starting
with that same basic code
that we had in the
previous example,
adding a little bit
of UI on top of that--
in this case, for adding a
map and a label on one side
and mapping a label
on the other side,
linking those two maps with
a function called linker
and adding a split
panel on top of that.
So with a few more
lines of code, now,
you're able to go
into Earth Engine
and scroll back and forth and
see NDVI, and how that relates
to the imagery underneath.
So a pretty useful tool
for analyzing that data.
And again, as a farmer,
you might care a lot
about how that data
is changing over time.
So, in this code, I've added
another panel at the bottom
with this code here and added
a series chart to that panel.
And so, when I click
on the map, that's
going to show me the NDVI over
time with that zero to one
range where NDVI is grounded.
And you can see that, generally
speaking for this farmer,
overall, in 2018, the
NDVI looks pretty good.
In July 18, it looks
like there was probably
a cloud over the farm.
So that's why that's
showing us a low number.
The last demo I have here is
going to run a comparison,
just adding another
time series chart,
running comparison
between 2017 and 2018.
So, as that comes up,
we'll have NDVI for 2017
on the left-hand side, NDVI for
2018 on the right-hand side.
And we'll start
to see comparisons
between the two data sets.
And that'll start to
give us an answer of,
how healthy are the fields?
How much vegetation is on those
fields one year versus another?
And so, again, clicking
on roughly that same spot
and looking at the
results, we can
see that the NDVI in
2018 at the bottom,
here, was higher for most of
the year than it was in 2017.
So this is all using data
that's in the public catalog.
You can bring your own
data into this, as well,
and using components
that are easily
available in Earth
Engine to let you inspect
that data in various ways.
So going back into the slides--
so we've spent a lot of time--
a few minutes-- in
the Code Editor,
which is where we do
interactive analysis.
We've started to get a
simple answer for one farmer.
If you want to do
that at scale, that's
where you start using Earth
Engine's batch capability.
So that allows you
to scale globally.
So you've got
thousands of farmers
that you're serving
around the world--
lets you automate runs
and lets you basically
take advantage of Earth
Engine's parallel computing
architecture.
And on the right, here,
we've got an example
from not the agriculture
space, but from work
that we did with the European
JRC, Joint Research Centre,
where they wanted to attract
surface water over the course
of 30 years where our
service water been
changing over 30 years--
ended up being 10 million
hours of computation.
We put 10,000 CPUs
against it, which
allowed the computation to
finish in less than two days.
So when do you really
want to run a big job,
Earth Engine can help with that.
And if you want to build Earth
Engine analysis into an app,
into a web page,
into a mobile app,
Earth Engine APIs
allow you to do that.
It gives your users the ability
to customize their data,
customize the answers
that they want
and basically get a lot of
value and power of Earth Engine
without writing code
editor code themselves.
So that's another feature
where Earth Engine can
help you scale your
analysis, have greater
impact with your
analysis, help it
reach more and
more of your users
in a way that makes sense.
So it's my last slide.
If you are interested
in Earth Engine--
you think it might be able
to help you solve some
of your problems faster--
you can go to
earthengine.google.com,
click Sign Up.
And Earth Engine's
free to evaluate.
And you can start
kicking the tires,
start using the Code Editor, the
APIs, or whatever makes sense
to you, and take it from there.
That's all I have.
Thank you very much
for your attention--
appreciate you listening.
And, yeah, thanks for coming.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]